bài tróng kênh thuộc vi vấn sất điện rất là nhiều. Nhưng nó giận rất là phùa, và vẫn còn tốt trạm bời.
Tìa thịt này là để này sẽ ăn một đi sất là xác để chính thức của những bất trọng là bà đi,
thêm hãngi, anh, để trọng, để trọng, để xác, với cấu chức để chính thức,
và phùa, em rất là đi chính thức thì sẽ trọng đi hã tình.
Sao là đi đi nghẹ, và của cô để đi thình mà.
Nhà, tu sao đi, thì thì mình sẽ đánh ra nó để, mình nó cao về tốt chúc.
Nó chúc để anh nó để hãi và của mình để tìa rất là phùa, để cân được tạm.
Và hiểu bọn các bạn để uống tìa đặt tạm tốt, để này nó tốt.
Hồi nếu mà đặt đừng bùa điểm của bỏ rỏ,
mình có chính thịt năm thì sẽ nghĩ là thức ngả, hả rỏ rồi rồi.
Nhà kênh nhá.